In the small town of Sulphur, Oklahoma, one of the most popular hangouts...
...is a lemonade stand run by six-year-old A'layah Robinson.
I'm in charge!
Whose idea was this?
Mine.
A'layah even has a business card.
Aren't you a little young to have your own business?
No.
But Lemonade for Love is not for profit.
A'layah is on a mission to help children who suffer...
...just like she and her brothers did.
They were tossed from home to home to home to home for neglect or abuse and...
...this happened in the foster care system.
When Misty Robinson adopted the siblings,...
...A'layah's younger brother didn't own a single toy.
Heartbroken, A'layah, then 4, came up with a goal.
In her mind, she wants to provide every single foster child with a toy.
In the world?
In the world.
They started with Oklahoma.
Please come see me and buy some lemonade.
She made 136 dollars with her lemonade stand, and so we just went from there.
It just kept getting bigger and bigger.
The Robinson family recruited volunteers,...
...shared their story on social media...
...and have since raised enough money to pack gift bags...
...for more than a thousand foster care children.
A'layah the foster child, now a local celebrity,...
...turning lemons into love.
Jacob Rascon, NBC News, Sulphur, Oklahoma.